the United States of America currently
has 40-year high inflation the last
print was at 8.6 percent we haven't seen
that since the 1980s and of course
there's many people who are asking
themselves how did we get here now
there's some things in the supply chain
that have been disrupted there's
obviously geopolitical issues like the
Russia Ukraine conflict but really most
of it was driven by undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy as we got the
covid pandemic all of a sudden the
government and the Central Bank decided
they needed to step into the market they
went ahead and they dropped interest
rates to zero and they pumped liquidity
into every exotic corner of the
financial system that they could find
all of that loose monetary policy and
all of those loose fiscal policies ended
up handing tons and tons of free cash to
American which sounded like a great idea
at the time according to them but
unfortunately when you go ahead and
create so much free money and you just
hand it out to people it ends up driving
inflationary pressures higher and we get
that 8.6 inflation that we're now facing
today now the state of California they
didn't seem to have learned from this
past lesson they just announced a brand
new effort where they're gonna hand more
free cash directly to their citizens the
governor of California Gavin Newsom
states that millions of Californians
will now be receiving up to one thousand
and fifty dollars as part of a new
middle class tax rebate that's more
money in their pockets to help them fill
up their gas tanks and put food on the
table it's pretty insane that the
government thinks they have to give a
thousand dollars to these individuals
just to fill up their gas tank or to put
food on their table that's warning sign
number one if you start to look deeper
and deeper into what's going on here
what you can find is they're doing this
via some sort of tax rebate it's part of
a 17 billion dollar relief package and
about 9.5 billion of it is going towards
these inflation relief funds it'll go to
about 23 million California taxpayers
and those folks can receive anywhere
between two hundred dollars and one
thousand and fifty dollars but they may
not get it until early next year if we
then take a look single tax filers they
can receive anywhere between 200 and 350
dollars if somebody's making between 125
000 and a quarter of a million dollars
per year State of California give it 200
bucks hope that fills your gas tank and
put some food on the table if you look
at joint tax filers what you'll see here
is that if you make between a quarter of
a million and half a million dollars per
year well they'll give you four hundred
dollars again fill up your gas tank baby
and make sure you got food on the table
as we go and we take a look at these
policies what we are watching is that it
appears politicians do not learn even if
those history lessons are only two years
old handing out free money two citizens
in this manner simply drives higher and
higher inflation pressures what we need
instead is to allow the free market to
work rather than turn around and hand
out money to people instead what we
should be doing is we should be
incentivizing economic growth and we
should actually be allowing the free
market to work one thing that we do know
is certain is that high gas prices are
here and they don't appear to be going
away we also know that food the cost of
it to eat at home is up 12 over the last
12 months it sounds great when a
government says that they're going to
hand you free money it sounds amazing
when they say they're going to help you
fill up your gas tank or put food on
your table the problem is we're talking
about giving 400 dollars to households
that make between a quarter of a million
and half a million dollars per year this
is absolutely insane so the state of
California is going to spend 9.5 billion
dollars to hand out a couple hundred
dollars to individuals but at the end of
the day it doesn't solve the problem
what it does is it simply drives higher
inflationary pressures and it allows for
the problem to persist if you want to
recognize that inflation is a problem if
you want to recognize that your citizens
are suffering you need to think from
first principles and you need to solve
the pressures of inflation not simply
hand out more money because it makes it
sound good we're going into midterm
elections and don't think that there's
not a connection between election season
and Free Money Getting handed out some
people would even argue this is the
equivalent of literally trying to buy
votes now I'm not going to go that far
and say that's what they're doing but
what I am going to say is that this type
of effort sounds great in theory but it
absolutely gets destroyed when you get
into reality handing free money to
people in this manner is not effective
for actually solving the problem does it
give them a couple hundred bucks in
their pocket absolutely but if you're
not going to give them the money until
early the next year potentially and
you're also not going to solve the
actual first principles problem
then all you're doing is grandstanding
and you're wasting 9.5 billion dollars
to the California state budget just so
you can go on Twitter tweet about how
cool you are and how you're looking out
for the citizens at the end of the day
this doesn't help them nearly as much as
you think it does and it may even make
the problem worse